the data are in the science is settled
america is getting super duper gay
there is a gallup poll out that shows
you know what
great respect i have for science and
data uh gallup poll comes out
and shows that america is getting
extremely gay
specifically that's not specific enough
america is identifying much more
as l g b
t and you know this is a little
complicated because
the l and the g s presuppose that there
are
biological sexes and you know men are
men and women are women and
gay guys or men who are attracted to men
and lesbians or women who are attracted
to women
but then the t comes in and confounds
all of that because the t
presupposes that there's not really any
such thing as men or women and women can
become men and
men can become women and you're not
really born this way you know everything
is kind of fluid and changing
all the time so it's very very confused
but the number of
americans who identify with any of those
letters increasing pretty dramatically
the traditional percentage of americans
who identify this way
it's about two percent maybe maybe
goes up to three percent by 2017 that
number rose
to four and a half percent so it rose
pretty significantly
and then in just the last four years
that number's risen again
very significantly to 5.6 so it's
getting
quicker and quicker but the the
more curious number is when you drill
down into the generations
because for americans born before 1965
the number of lgbt identifying americans
is around two percent a little bit less
than two percent
when you get to millennials that number
jumps
to about 9.1 percent
that is pretty pretty high then
when you get to gen z
that number jumps extremely high that
jumps to 15.9 percent
of americans i
have to believe that there is some
biological basis for sexual desire
you know there's this kind of debate are
you born this way or
does culture do it you know i don't
think that you just sort of freely
choose your sexual desires so i i don't
think for instance that liberace
was ever going to end up married to a
woman i just that just does not seem
very likely to me however
i don't think that sixteen percent of
zoomers
just so happen to be born this way right
with all these sort of
ever-expanding uh alphabet identities i
don't
if the numbers were increasing that
dramatically
i i would have to assume there's
something in the water
if the numbers were if it was purely a
biological thing
100 and the numbers were increasing that
way alex jones would have to be right
right there
they're turning the frickin zoomers gay
right that would or
not yeah i guess more t or g
or b or you know it kind of gets very
complicated which is kind of my point i
think human sexuality is just a very
complicated thing and there are all
these different factors in here
but surely surely
politics and culture plays some role in
this
as well you know i did a book club
episode not that long ago
with spencer clavin and we were
discussing plato's symposium
and plato's symposium is very strange
for modern readers to read
because it's basically a big gay dinner
party and so a lot of
modern sort of conservatives or
christians will read this and say wait a
second
what's going on here and there's a huge
cultural factor at play in these sorts
of
behaviors the reason this poll
i think matters is because right now if
cultural and political factors
have some role here the cultural and
political factors
are all pushing in one direction namely
away from a sort of traditional
understanding of these sexual questions
toward a much more radical one i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the michael
knowles show to check out the full
episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
you